the jurogan experience here's what i'm
worried about
i'm worried that they've that it's now
been proven
that someone with a lot of money who's
outside the system
can win and can actually become the
president
the worry that i have is not just that
someone
worse than him tries to do it again but
someone who's like really truly evil
the other worry is that the other side
tries to prevent that from happening
and by doing so they justify
hamstringing democracy
like they decide like look we can't ever
let this happen again so we need a
concerted
effort where we coordinate with the
media we coordinate with the
all of the different intelligence
communities
and we figure out a way to pick pick the
people that we
want to win and attack the person that
we don't
because that's how banana republics get
started
okay and that's how people get
assassinated and that's how people
justify a lot of wild
[ __ ] they justify because they think
ultimately it's imperative
for the future of our nation if this
person doesn't win and our person gets
in there
and they think so so zealously that
they're willing to do
wild [ __ ] and that's what happens in
other countries and we were talking
before this podcast about
they killed the president of haiti
yesterday yeah that's
right would you say that i'm so
disappointed
in myself because i just i just feel
like like as a black person when i hear
black news from a white person
like [ __ ] that i should know like i
should have known before you
that the president of haiti got
assassinated well to be honest i'm
really up on assassinations i follow all
the assassination twitter pages
i'm on assassination twitter there's an
assassination twitter
i'm just guessing oh okay i say i'm
missing out i just pay attention to new
[ __ ] a squad of gunman assassinated
haitian president how do you say his
name jovanelle
moyes jamie
i'm sorry who did his wife in an
overnight raid on his home
on their home on wednesday inflicting
more chaos in the caribbean country that
was already enduring gang violence
soaring inflation
and protests of its increasingly
authoritarian rule
wow prime minister claude joseph
well what's scary about this kind of
stuff is uh you know
who knows who's going to take over now
you know when someone assassinates
the president they don't want that
president in there for what what
various reasons so who's going to come
in now how much worse is it going to be
for the haitian people
how much what kind of person is going to
try to take over now i feel like it's
been pretty bad for haitian people for a
lot i don't know if it's ever been good
well i mean i was telling you earlier
that that's the first
slave that's the only slave rebellion in
history that works
it says uh beauchette edmond the haitian
ambassador to the united states said the
attack on the 53 year old moyes
i'm not saying is i don't know if i'm
saying his name right moisei
m-o-i-s-e was carried out by
foreign mercenaries and professional
killers well orchestrated
and that they were masquerading as
agents of the u.s drug enforcement
administration
the dea has an office in the haitian
capital to assist
the government in counter narcotics
programs according to the us embassy
well if drugs were legal over there they
wouldn't have no that's that's not true
they've been whacking people like this
man but but see
i'll be on some game of thrones [ __ ]
like i don't i don't even trust this
[ __ ] i'm like maybe he has
something to do with it
you know so true you never know it's
it's so hard to know well by the time
the news gets to someone like you or me
who the [ __ ] knows yeah it's the steal
who knows because
well that that's what's so funny to me
is i feel like we're this we're the same
as
china we we it's just that we're all
convinced
we're all convinced that we're not being
controlled
but they just have a different method of
doing it you know like
over there the government was straight
up just be like yeah we're spying on you
yeah and over here they're still spying
on you they you just convinced that they
aren't or that it's not so bad but they
it's the same outcome they know
everything you're doing and every move
you make
we just feel free like like the [ __ ] you
brought up about edward snowden right
yeah
you would expect that kind of
information to make people rebel
but but some people rebelled some people
were furious well
i heard that um i heard julian assange
like he had a quote that was like i
don't know the exact [ __ ]
but the sentiment was just that
all people really care about is their
sense of freedom
not their actual freedoms so you can
tell about you can tell a [ __ ]
you can tell a bunch of [ __ ]
the government is spying on you
collecting all your messages listening
to all your phone calls
all your purchases everything but you
feel free and people don't give a [ __ ]
because you feel free
more people gave a [ __ ] about having to
wear a mask than the government spying
on them because
that that makes you feel less free yes
and that's what we're lazy like that and
the thing about the government having
that power it's actually bad for them
because it's not it's too much
responsibility because you have to lie
about it first of all because you're not
supposed to have that kind of power
you're not supposed to be able to just
spy on people randomly because at the
end of the day
the government is comprised of people
and we're people
so it's just people spying on people and
you're doing it through initials oh
we're the fbi and the nsa
and the dea and the blah blah you're
just people spying on people
reinforcing laws that were written down
on paper
by who the [ __ ] knows who and who knows
who the [ __ ] knows if those laws are
valid
in 2021 anymore with all the technology
we have today
with the abilities to do things today
are so much greater than
what these laws were established about
like in the 1970s or 1960s
and even then yeah i'm i'm on some
george carla's [ __ ]
yeah your freedom is an illusion the
only thing that exists
is comfort and violence you
you have you have comforts and you
either have the you
have the the ability to to use violence
to maintain it or not
yeah but that's really all it is like if
you you can you can create this utopia
with all these rules
but if you can't enforce the rules it
doesn't [ __ ] matter so you violence
will always be a part of the world
authoritarianism [ __ ] it just comes
to violence
honestly in this country i'm almost less
concerned because
if it comes to violence in this country
i just
i can't imagine how the government is
like legitimately going to take over
when a lot of the people that are
actually in the military would have to
turn on the people that they grew up
with
they would have to turn on the people
that they that they love in their
communities
because the government tells them to at
the end of the day the people that
protect us
it's the military the government is the
people that direct the military
but you're there's a push comes to shove
there
you're never really going to take over
this country in a military way
because the military are the people that
will not want you to do that
because they wouldn't trust these
weasley politicians that would try to do
that
yeah i think at the end of the day more
people would
would challenge who
they'd be more attached to who is in
charge of them than the coos president
or who's in the government yeah
that would be hard to do it'd be really
hard to get the government
to control the military to the point
where the military turns on regular
people
really hard because they're not the idea
is like that the elites
are going to control the world but the
elites are not the military
they're elite human beings they're
they're elite soldiers
but there are not elites in terms of
like the one percent of the world
they're regular folks for the most part
so getting regular folks to turn on
regular folks because the elites tell
them to
that's one of those weird like how do
you do this things
so the way to control populations is
through propaganda
and re-education of their youth turning
people on each other like if you really
wanted to [ __ ] up a future community
you would uh you know distribute
propaganda to their children
teach their children to feel bad about
themselves and that this this country
and this society is
a mistake and a disaster and the worst
thing to ever happen and we need to burn
it down
if you taught that to kids over and over
and over again those kids grow
up well you have a real shot at [ __ ]
things up because you can ruin
all of the structures that have kept
societies together
and then if you accompany that if you
accompany that with things like
defund the police whoa and we're not
going to prosecute anybody for anything
less than 950 bucks
oh wait that depends on what now you got
all the money
yeah you got open looting you got chaos
you cops scared to arrest people you got
elevated
crime rates catch new episodes of the
joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience